It's painful to understand how much of
what you're doing isn't productive.
So I'll give you an example.
So I've done this a couple of times with
classrooms full of students.
Usually when I'm lecturing about career
development,
say,
okay,
um,
how much time do you waste?
So then I get the class to vote.
How many of you waste a 10 hours a day?
It's like 10 percent of the kids will
put up their hands.
And it's interesting because I don't
define what constitutes waste.
I just asked the question.
So they're diagnosing themselves,
right?
I'm not saying you're wasting 10 hours a
day.
I'm just asking.
It's like given your own attitude,
how much time you wasting 10 hours a
day.
It's like 10 percent of the people put
up their hands.
Well when you get to like six hours a
day,
80 percent of the people put up their
hands.
So then we do the arithmetic.
It's like,
because I like doing arithmetic with
people.
People hate arithmetic,
but I like doing it.
It's like,
okay,
six hours a day,
42 hours a week.
So let's call that a work week.
Forty hours a week,
so,
so that's,
that's a work week,
let's say what's your time worth,
your university student or certainly
worth minimum wage because obviously,
but it's worth way more than that
because if you spend a productive hour
when you're 20 than you gain the
benefits of that hour for the rest of
your life.
So there's the compounding effect of
time spent when we were young.
So I say,
well let's assume your time's worth 50
bucks an hour,
which I think is an underestimate,
but whatever.
Let's call it 50.
We call it 25,
but we'll call it 50.
That's $2,000
a week.
You're wasting it's $100,000
a year.
It's like,
how much better would your life be if
you weren't wasting $100,000
a year?
It's like,
what is that?
Over 40 years,
$4,000,000.
It's like you're rich.
You don't even know it.
Quit wasting time by your own
definition.
It's like people shake their heads like,
oh,
I never thought about it that way.
It's like,
yeah,
think about it that way.
Don't waste your damn life.
And then you think,
well,
why would people be resistant to that
message?
It's like,
well,
you really want to wake up and figure
out that you're wasting half your life
and you know,
when people do that kind of wasting,
they actually hate it.
You know?
And I've had lots of people come to my
clinical practice who were chronic
procrastinators,
you know,
and so they're watching youtube videos
say,
but,
but not ones that are good for them,
although sometimes they will do that,
but just browsing and that kind of
mindless way that you do when you're not
paying attention and you're trying to
kill time and people doing that,
they feel bad,
they get depressed,
they feel anxious,
they can't get away from it.
They feel kind of addicted.
Saying about social media now.
It's a huge issue with young kids.
Absolutely.
But there's this feeling of kind of
internal rot and corruption that goes
along with it.
It's like,
yeah,
well you're wasting your life.
It's like,
so it's painful.
It's painful to recognize that.
Then it's painful to think,
oh my God,
look how undisciplined I am.
I don't know anything.
I can't use this schedule.
I can't.
I can't stick to a calendar.
I don't have any aims.
I don't know anything about the world.
Right.
And maybe there's a part of me that's
bitter because I haven't got everything
already and I'd like to say to hell with
it.
That's the recognition of the union
shadow.
It's like that's what makes you a
vicious and,
and,
and untrustworthy all of that.
No one wants to look at that and no
bloody wonder.
But Hey,
the alternative is worse.